اكثر من اسبوع من على مضي اطلاق فيجن برو
من
من نظرات ابل الذكيه التي يقال انها راح
تغير قواعد اللعبه طبعا قبل
تروج لي نظراتها على انها جهاز
التكنولوجيا الشخصيه الاكثر تقدما حيث
تحتوي على اول نظام تشغيل في العالم يمزج
بين المحتوى الرقمي مع العالم المادي
منتجات النظارات الذكيه التي تعمل بتقنيات
الواقعه الافتراضيه او المعزز ليست جديده
دخلت الخدمه منذ اكثر من عقدين
لكنها لم تقدم التجربه المذهله التي
يتوقعها المستخدمون مقابل السعر بينما
ارتفعت توقعات بعد دخول السوق واعتبرت
لحظه فاصله لعصر جديد للنظرات الذكيه بل
سباق تسلح بالفعل
بالواقع المعزز في المشهد التقني
الزميله لميس ابراهيم في طله جديده الحديث
عن النظارات انواع النظارات الذكيه ماذا
لديك اي نوع من انواع النظارات كل الالوان
في ار ام ار
رغم السعر الماهر لنظاره ابل جديده يتوقع
المحللون ان تنجح في بيع ما يصل الى 150
الف من نظراتها بعد عام طرحها في الاسواق
لكن ما هي انواع النظارات الذكيه نظرات
الواقع الافتراضي في ار تعمل على عزل
مستخدم تماما عن العالم الخارجي ونقله
لبيئه رقميه جديده ولعل الى هذه التجارب
خرجت من شركه الالعاب
في التسعينات لكنها كانت مكلفه وغير فعاله
اما نظرات الواقع المعزز اي ار فتعمل على
دمج العناصر الرقميه في العالم المادي
بحيث يشعر المستخدم بان تلك العناصر جزء
من الواقع ابرز الامثله عليها لعبه
بوكيمون جو التي حققت ضجه عالميه في 2016
اخيرا نظرت الواقع المختلط ام ار وهي
التقنيه التي تعتمدها نظاره
ومايكروسوفت هولو لانس وميتو كويست وهي
مزيج يزيل الفوارق بين الواقع الافتراضي
والعالم الحقيقي بمعنى ان يكون نصفك في
العالم المادي والنصف الاخر يتفاعل مع
البيئات الرقميه
[موسيقى]
خل نروح الرياض بجيبنا 7000 اكثر من 7000
دولار تقريبا عشان نشوف فيصل السيف وهو
لابس النظر ليش تضحك فيصل يا اخي نعرف اول
شيء صبحك الله بالخير صباح الخير
وجعل يومكم خير وبركه يا رب
فيصل النظاره ابل شرح تفرق ليش مراهنين
عليها كثير لربما تفشل حالها حال اللي
فشله وسابقا
جميل اوكي مساله الفشل بعد دخول ابل نوعا
ما صارت نسبتها اقل بكثير بس ليش خلينا
ننتقل الى الاشياء والعالم اللي احنا
حاليا نعيشه في الواقع الافتراضي والواقع
المعزز اولها النظاره اللي انا قاعد من
خلالها اقدر اشوفكم بشكل جدا واقعي ولو
تلاحظوا المجال لان موجود فيه قاعدين
تشوفوه وايضا نشوف التعزيز اللي احنا
نتكلم عليه فعلى سبيل المثال لو تلاحظوا
عندكم هنا في الشاشه في اجسام واشياء
موجوده عندي خلال التدريب للناس وخلال
ايضا اقامه جلسات التدريب يمديكم يكون
عندكم اجسام موجوده مؤهله تقربوا عليها
تقدروا تشرحوا عليها وتقوموا بعمليات
تدريب وايضا توجيه جدا كامل هذا الامر كان
مستحيل اتكلم على الصندوق
زي الهليكوبتر اللي موجود هناك وفعليا
نقدر ناخذه تحكم فيه نقدر نشيله نقربه علي
اقدر اشوف القمره اللي موجوده اقدر فعليا
اخذها ابعدها اصغر الحجم من زاويه
اوكي اقدر اشيله
هناك اوديه المنطقه اللي هناك بل ايضا في
مجموعه اشياء جدا كثيره هنا اقدر اتفاعل
معاها
موجوده الا في واقع المعزز فقط بس بس انا
اسف فيصل ما بيدك شلون شلتها يعني على
الاقل قبل كان في حساسات اليوم ما في اي
صح
وهاد ممتاز هذه احدى التطورات اللي صارت
فلما اتكلم على الهولولينز المايكروسوفت
بس هذه كانت ترى اصدار الالفين وتسعه عشر
قبل اربع سنوات والتحكم من خلال اليدين بل
انه قائمه النوافذ الويندوز بيدي اضغط زي
كذا تلاقوا القائمه طلعت زي ما انتم
تشوفوا عندكم على الشاشه هذا فعليا كانك
قاعد تعيش افلام خيال علمي وهذا الامر من
اربع سنوات ما هو بالامر
تدخل بمنظومه الانتشار الضخمه حقتها
بذكرني يا فيصل
كان هو الواقع المعزز والكذا وكنا بنفكره
ضرب من الخيال ولكن هيو عم بيصير حقيقه
طيب كيف كيف
بتختلف يا فيصل هاي النظاره عن نظرات الفي
ار العاديه
ممتاز الواقع الممزوج اللي هي نقدر نقول
المعزز هو انكم تشوفوا طابق جهه فوق الجهه
حقتكم ففي نظاره شفافه زي ما انتم ملاحظين
الاوجمنتي او الفي ار الفيتش والريال
الافتراضي زي اللي موجوده مع ماهر هنا
ماهر الحين لاحظوا الشاشه هو داخل السياره
والله هو داخل السياره هذي ولو التفت ورا
يمديه حتى يشوف من النافذه الخلفيه
والسيارات وهو قاعد يعيش هذي التجربه بشكل
كامل الحين اذا جينا ودمجنا ما بين
التقنيتين الاولى والثانيه حيجي شيء اسمه
ميكست ريالتي الواقع الممزوج وهنا نيجي
للابتكارات اللي طلعت في السنوات الماضيه
وهالابتكارات اللي تثري المجال وقابليه
نجاح الحين اكثر بكثير
مقابل نجاحها اكثر هذا اللي انا ناطره منك
يا فيصل
ممتاز تخيلوا معايا يا جماعه انه هذه فقط
بعض الاجهزه اللي طلعت السنه الماضيه
بعضها واخر سنتين تقريبا وهذه الاجهزه
اكثركم ما سمع فيهم ولكن شركه ابل بمؤتمر
واحد خلت اكبر شريحه من الناس تتعرف عليها
المطورين اللي اول يقول يا اخي عدد
مستخدمين هالنظارات قليل ايش انا اطور
تطبيقات الحين بتشجعوا وايضا لما نتكلم
على الاعمال يقولوا لا صار فيه منظومه
متكامله من شركه عريقه تريليونيه تقدر
تطور معانا وتساندنا فهو الموضوع ما هو
بصدفه لا هو شيء واقعي يصير ومتاح طيب
فيصل نظرات ابل يعني تستخدم بايش للترفيه
فقط ولا ممكن يكون في الها استخدامات اخرى
ايضا
ممتاز بالنسبه لنظارات ابل حتكون اقرب
للمجالس الصناعي التعليمي التدريبي افضل
من مجال الترفيه 3500 دولار ابدا ومنطقيه
تكون على مجال الترفيه ولكن مجال التدريب
لما اجي انا في مصنع البس هذه النظاره
واشوف امامي نفس البايبات ومال البايبات
والاجهزه اللي موجوده بمجرد نظري عليها
اشوف كل عمود موجود ايش التقنيه اللي
يسويها او ايش الامر اللي يسويه فيجيني
ارشاد توجيهي لاني افتح هذا اسكر هذا في
التدريب في المصانع افضل ايضا لو نتكلم
على التدريب في اماكن السيارات والتصميم
لما تجوا تسووا سياره بحجم كبير في الواقع
الافتراضي هذه السياره شوفوا ادق تفاصيلها
من خلال النظارات اتخاذ القرار اسهل وارخص
لانه فعليا واقعيه الامر ما كلفنا كثير
غير الاستثمار في هذه المنظومه يوم تجي
نظارات من شركات اخرى هل النظاره تكلف ثلث
سعر نظاره ابل وهنا نجي للموضوع المربك
ثقيله الحين انتقل لعالم ثاني مختلف تفضل
حتى حتى كوزن انا قاعد اسال ممتاز
اكثر النظارات اللي تشوفوها وزنها يتراوح
من 300 الى حوالي 550 جرام تقريبا على
النظارات اللي لابسها كمبيوتر متكامل
موجود فيها التحكم يكون من خلال يديني او
من خلال نفس ايادي التحكم الاضافيه اللي
موجوده المستخدمين اي واحد قاعد يتفرج في
حلول موجوده للترفيه وايضا انكم تعيشوا
بلحظات مختلفه فيها على سبيل المثال
بامكانكم لحظيا تحطوا النظاره وتعيشوا
فيديو 360 درجه في الحرم شوفوا الحرم وقت
اثناء الجسر المؤقت في الوقت الحالي بل
ايضا في بث مباشر من مختلف مناطق العالم
وهذا البث المباشر يمكنكم انكم تعيشوا
لحظات من اماكن مختلفه الامر ما كان ابدا
حيكون واقع لو ما كان في تقنيات زي هذه
وفعلا لا شيء مستحيل وكل اشي ممكن يصير
يعني مع تكنولوجيا والتطور التكنولوجي
وفيصل انت يعني ما خليت اي نظاره تعتب
عليك كل النظارات ما شاء الله
كلهم اسواق تسالك لانه انت قلت عن الابل
الباقيين ثروه
هذي بسافر واعطني اياها مايكروسوفت الاولى
تقريبا ثلاثه ونص هنا نتكلم على 600 دولار
اللي قبلها شوي اللي السوده كانت حوالي
الف وشويه دولار بس اتاكد هذه اكثرها
للمطورين وليست متاهه منها للناس نعم لازم
تقيموا استثماراتكم الحين امر ثاني تخيلوا
انكم تلبسوا نظاره وتعيشوا 360 درجه داخل
درون او طياره وهذا الامر ممكن من اكثر من
سنه مجرد ما البس هذه النظاره اقدر اكون
راكب في قمره القياده هنا والكاميرا اللي
موجوده هنا تحاكي اتجاه نظري او اتجاه
راسي فلما اطالع يمين الدرون نفسه او يسار
الدرول بيطالع معاي لما اروح الجهه
الثانيه
فتخيلوا كانكم تطيروا في السحاب وتتحكموا
براحتك ارسل لي ارسل لي على الواتساب اسم
هذه
الكاميرا وهذه هذا الدرون شكرا تسلم
لعيونك تسلم يا فيصل السيف المؤثر في
التقنيه وصانع المحتوى ان شاء الله صاحبك
وصل بالسلامه خله ينزل من هالسباق
والله راح طلع من بوحدريه
ضرب من الخيال اعاده الكل لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات